le 12 mai dernier les élections
provinciales en nouvelle calédonie ont
permis de renouveler les assemblées de
province et le congrès de la nouvelle
calédonie famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens à un agent m'en a largement
remporté ce scrutin puisque avec 41% des
voix dans la province sud nous
occupèrent nous occupons désormais 20
des sièges sur l'e40 à pourvoir
nous avons également obtenu 3 sièges
dans la province nord à majorité
indépendantiste mais ce scrutin vient
confirmer les résultats du référendum du
4 novembre dernier au cours duquel le
non l'a emporté à raison de 50 7% des
suffrages
le non à l'indépendance donc
majoritairement le 12 mai les
calédoniens ont réaffirmé qu'ils veulent
rester français et ce message ne
s'adresse pas seulement aux
gouvernements ne s'adresse pas seulement
aux premiers ministres
ce message s'adresse à la france il
s'adresse à nous dans sept ans dans cet
hémicycle
nous incarnons la représentation
nationale
malgré ces résultats la nouvelle
calédonie se retrouve aujourd'hui dans
une situation totalement absurde par un
jeu d'alliances
c'est un indépendantiste qui a été élu à
la tête de la précise à l'ats à la tête
du congrès et dans quelques jours il
n'est pas impossible que le même
scénario se renouvelle par l'élection
d'un indépendantiste comme président du
gouvernement pour la majorité des cas
les données à cette situation est
incompréhensible voire un tollé cette
majorité a le sentiment que le résultat
du référendum
le résultat des élections du 12 mai lui
ont été confisqués et que son choix d'un
avenir dans la france est ignoré cette
majorité a même l'impression qu'on
l'emmène subrepticement là où elle ne
veut pas alors monsieur le projet nice
pour clarifier cette situation et avant
que cette situation ne dégénère
les élus avenir en confiance au congrès
de la nouvelle-calédonie demanderont
ganisation le plus tôt possible du
second référendum prévu par l'accord de
nouméa donc peu concluants presse
monsieur le président monsieur premier
nice êtes vous prêts à nous accompagner
en organisant le plus tôt possible
ce deuxième référendum je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
en l'absence du premier ministre que
j'ai excusé la parole est à madame la
ministre d outre-mer madame girard dont
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur pierre frogier vous l'avez dit
le 12 mai les électeurs de nouvelle
calédonie se sont donc prononcés pour
élire leurs représentants dans leurs
institutions du territoire aujourd'hui
les présidents et vice présidents des
provinces ont été élus ainsi que le
président et les responsables des
instances du congrès de nouvelle
calédonie le congrès vient d'ailleurs de
prononcer de se prononcer sur le nombre
de membres du gouvernement de nouvelle
calédonie il procédera à son élection le
13 juin prochain je veux ici en mon nom
et ensuite du président du premier
ministre vous re dire et redire à
l'ensemble des élus nos félicitations
qu'ils soient effectivement à la
province ou au congrès leur mandat est
le dernier de l'accord de nouméa qui a
été signé en 1998 vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le sénateur à la veille du 12
mai en évoquant l'obligation de trouver
une solution partagée pour l'avenir de
la nouvelle calédonie elle ne peut
passer et vous le savez le premier
ministre l'a dit souvent que par le
dialogue et par le respect en décembre
dernier lors du dernier comité des
signataires nous étions donc tous
ensemble et nous sommes donné rendez
vous à l'issue de cette série
d'élections élections provinciales
congrès et gouvernement nous tiendront
effectivement ce rendez vous dès les
élections du 13 juin prochain
vous avez vous m'avez questionné sur le
deuxième référendum
et bien cet accord effectivement prévoit
qu'un tiers des membres du congrès peu
sollicité l'organisation d'un deuxième
référendum
je voudrais donc vous dire monsieur le
sénateur qu'il faut que cette démarche
soit faite et bien entendu comme le veut
l'accord nous organiserons ce référendum
et je veux vous redire ici que le
premier ministre va donner une date de
rendez vous très vite parce que nous
devant reprendre le chemin du dialogue
vous savez que c'est l'essentiel pour la
nouvelle calédonie